I welcome welcome to this video playing
step by step the national master from
Bulgaria there's no name but i played
him a number of times also with winner
accounts okay the king's indian play the
age three line again so just posing into
a Ben Oni check yeah this is yeah
amazing how often you get this line and
it's simply bit simply bad but I had it
had it only recently and forgot forgot
the refutation so maybe it's his right
to play that but it gets tricky I mean
Luke f1 how do you protect up seven or
the check that's the way to protect f7
but black resigns yeah sure should I
even upload this okay one minute playing
time yeah yeah black has already lost in
this position he cannot play 95 at all
check 30 sorry this yes nor no other
moves and TM I'm coming with rook f1
tripling and I'm breaking through 107
yeah again this is a quick game I'm
doing a quick review of the opening
Bishop h8 is not a good move here h6 is
not a good news but i can try here
especially if since we're talking about
a blitz game you can sacrifice the
exchange here check for a poem this is
an interesting way to play trying to
regroup and then use the e5 square okay
but this is sometimes played rook takes
it to is considered to be too risky as
I'm getting
quickly even to age six in most lines
yeah and this I think black can try to
play like that and I had a game recently
where it didn't really refute it and the
main setup is doubling on the F file and
increasing the pressure along the sand
on this file the way he played at them
and says mentioned and loses some uses
immediately so I'm it's an interesting
that you get this against the title
player it's very well known that this
line is not not so reliable for black
maybe with very very accurate play you
can avoid an immediate disaster but it's
it's difficult to do alright thanks for
watching